la reine des abeilles à l'honneur au
traitant Palace de Versailles pour
Pâques Eddy benghane proposera cette
année une cinquantaine de créations
chocolatées elles seront vendues au
tarif de 49 euros clients de l'hôtel et
de l'extérieur le chef pâtissier
installé dans l'hôtel depuis 14 ans
voulait rappeler les souvenirs d'enfance
et plaire au plus jeune les enfants pas
que c'est Maya l'abeille pour nous cette
année c'est vrai qu'on s'est à chaque
fois qu'on l'apprend on la prend en
photo Maya l'abeille on a tous un
sourire parce qu'elle est trop drôle
elle a des lunettes bon bah il est
peut-être un petit peu trop danse avec
moi ce que j'aime bien les lunettes mais
elle est drôle elle est elle est
rigolote et elle parle à plein de
générations différentes c'est aussi
notre symbole donc le symbole du Trianon
de Versailles de la royauté et l'abeille
c'est quelque chose de très très
important le lundi 10 avril 8 personnes
vont également travailler sur un grand
afternoon tee en 7 séquence salé et
sucré qui sera proposé dans le salon
Clemenceau dans l'assiette vous pourrez
notamment déguster une tarte au petit
pois et à la burrata un pinceau fait à
l'encre de seiche concombre et saumon
fumé il y a un moelleux noisette et
poire on fait souvent des repas entre
nous et je me suis dit ça serait super
sympa d'avoir une séquence complète pour
être cohérent constant et puis
participer aussi à l'expérience et
comment voilà comment peut-on faire un
peu plus pour nos clients comment
peut-on plus les leur faire plaisir les
choyer et les chouchouter quoi ce petit
time se retard de 75 euros pour les
adultes et 40 euros pour les enfants en
parallèle des animations seront
également proposées pour les plus jeunes
pour la journée dans cet hôtel
historique créé en 1910
[Musique]